whenever he would take his Shades off he
had this thing about him that I love no
matter what was going on around us he
was like always
kind of squinting but like his eyes were
wide open on Friday friends family and
fans gathered to honor takeoff who was
fatally shot in Houston on November 1st
now his family cardi B offset and cuevo
are paying tribute to the late rapper on
social media
and the left hand of Richard Mille cardi
B who is married to takeoff's cousin and
Migos co-member offset shared several
snaps alongside a lengthy caption that
read in part quote the impact you had in
this world was so considerable and we
have struggled to grasp this tragedy
cardi added that she is heartbroken but
grateful for all the precious memories
they share quote this has truly been a
nightmare and the pain is incomparable I
pray that you give offset quavo and your
friends and family the strength to keep
going as they are trying to cope with
this loss
[Music]
as for offset he swapped out his profile
picture to feature takeoff while cuevo
penned a letter to his late nephew which
he shared alongside a simple caption
dear take in the post cuevo recalled
takeoff's passion for music calling him
the quietest and funniest person in any
room before adding quote this whole time
I've been trying to figure what you
really are to me because nephew wasn't
it now I finally get it you are our
angel
Christmas
is
[Music]
Chloe Bailey Justin Bieber Yolanda Adams
and Byron Cage performed at the rapper
celebration of life in Atlanta while
Drake cuevo and offset spoke at the
emotional Gathering Gucci Mane city
girls Rich the kid Russell Simmons
murder beats YG Lil yachty CeeLo Green
and Tiana Taylor were among the guests
in attendance
it's devastating he was
my abiding memory of him
was it just was so kind he was so laid
back he was funny
he'd always call me big drip if I saw
him which he knew I just loved E.T spoke
to James Corden following the news of
takeoff's tragic death and he recalled
the time he spent with the musician
while shooting a segment of carpool
karaoke
[Music]
like I never knew until I heard the news
of his passing that the reason he was
called takeoff was because often he
would just record all his verses in one
take and that was it he was such an
accomplished musician
what he did like he changed the needle
on trap music and in his official obit
takeoff was remembered as a most gentle
soul quote there are no words or
sentiments conveyed that could aptly
Encompass the love so many had for him
and the impact he made on this world
[Music]
foreign